[Music]
let's go to john in las
cruces new mexico what's up man
hi john how are you outstanding how are
you
i'm good thanks uh the reason i'm
calling is long story short
i'm pretty sure my son is uh bipolar and
schizophrenic
he's an adult i
can't do anything for him you know like
i can't ground him i can't force him to
go to counseling or anything like that
but i sure wish i knew what to do you
know
tell me how did you come to this
realization
well he's been he's been quite the
consumer of cannabis for over a decade
now
um and then past weekend or about this
past weekend before last
he was at his mom's he lives with his
mom he's 26
um was in the backyard uh basically
attacking a shrub with a pair of
whoppers
and for preparing the backyard for an
in-ground pool
and a basketball hoop um and
his step-dad went out to try and get the
loppers um things got physical
uh my son got arrested and put in jail
uh went before the judge and the judge
can see he was struggling
and he's been in a psychiatric ward
hospital
for a week now okay um and then
based on a conversation my mom who has a
master's degree in art therapy
had with his mom she said you know this
is just her opinion she made it very
clear she's not you know the expert
but she thinks that's what's going on
okay um
as an example my son told me one time
that his mom and her husband were
sharpening their teeth
with forks at the dinner table um
so there's is it's some pretty how to
control stuff is
i guess the most polite way to put it
sure um
first and foremost man when you love
somebody and they're struggling with
with mental illness when they're
institutionalized i know that blows up
your whole world
and i hate that for you man i've sat
with too many parents in psych wards
and it's it's one of the more
heartbreaking
moments i've spent in my career so i
hate that for you guys
um i know it's been a tough tough couple
of weeks
when you and him are just hanging out
is he lucid with you can y'all go
fishing can y'all go work on a farm out
there
can y'all i mean can y'all go do stuff
together
well it's it's been a long time since
we've hung out
um how come well i
i i'm in the transportation business
okay i
drive cross country yep and you know
he's up in a different city with his mom
um and there have been times when i've
gone through his town
and i'm like hey i'm coming through and
you know for well over a year now he
hasn't had a car because it got hit by
lightning and coveted and all that stuff
and
then there were times where he would
just kind of blow me off um or could
make it happen um so we haven't had a
quality connect time
for a while now and let me back up about
five years
ago he was um smoking spice
and i threw a red flag at that right
away i got hit with oh no no i've done
my research
you know i'm driving i'm on the fly so
uh okay you know i mean what
like i said a minute ago what am i going
to do ground him you know
and um about a week or two whatever
later
he wound up in a psych ward because he
cooked his brain yeah
they held him there for three days they
let him go
um as i understand he was supposed to go
to counseling he didn't
or he went once then blew it off okay um
so you know are you are you still in
contact with
his mom yes sir
well she only calls me if there's an
emergency okay
so so this is an emergency so here's a
couple of things
um first i don't um
anytime somebody says they got diagnosed
bipolar and schizophrenic
my my
i don't think so goes up my my flag goes
up there
um i don't put a lot of stock
into that dual diagnosis and so
um usually it's some how you just
mentioned it
it's some sort of armchair um
uh somebody that hasn't googled it or
has enough
something like this or a small town i
just don't hear a lot of
people in the literature and hear a lot
of um full-time professional
diagnosticians
giving that comorbid diagnosis okay
that that dual diagnosis um so what i
would do is
um wait till if i'm you i'd get in the
car and go
go meet with the doctors myself and i
would call my
my ex-wife or his mom or whatever
relationship you have to her
and y'all got to come up with some sort
of plan um
you're right i smoking weed it usually
is
a um did y'all have a pretty tumultuous
childhood there
i don't think that he did i mean you
know his mom and i split when he was
four or five okay so yes he did have a
tumultuous childhood he did
you might not feel that he did but he
did um okay
so whatever it looks like as he ages out
and gets older
smoking weed is is doesn't make me lose
my hair
i will throw every red flag i've got on
smoke and spice for that very reason
i've
seen students lose everything over that
deal they just like you you perfect
words it cooks their brain
right and so i've been there i've seen
that
um i would have a circle the wagons game
plan
and ultimately what you're going to need
to do is get true diagnosis from a true
psychiatrist and sit down with somebody
and say what are we dealing with here
and then come up with some sort of plan
between you and
his mom and him and then you're right he
doesn't get to put i mean he can choose
not to participate he's 26 years old
and what he's going to end up is either
on the street or he's getting up in some
sort of group home
on government assistance or if it's
schizophrenia he can take medication and
ha and
do counseling and he can have a
productive great life right but it's
finding that right group is going to
connect with him or that right
professional
who's going to dial in the meds and get
some the the care
that he needs um usually that takes
everybody in his circle talking
the same language and that means you
and his stepdad and and
her getting on the same page
right right and the problem i'm running
into in his mom
is well he signed paperwork that they
can give and hit her
limited information just generalizations
about
what's going on right um you know what
the doctors are seeing that whole thing
right um he's still in denial about
what happened and why he's there sure
you know like oh you know
he called me the other day and
apologized for his silly mistake
i.e that he grabbed a hold of the ex of
the stepdad
sure you know and so that's
i i'm not i don't know how much
information
i'm gonna get let alone his mom um who
lives in a different city like i said
with him
you know um right that's where
that's where your partnership with a
doctor or often there's a social worker
that helps run helps communicate between
patients like this and parents and
families
and community support groups
here's what i'm telling you i if i'm you
i'm on the phone with every single
person i can
i would take off a work if at all
possible or try to route myself through
this community
the way forward is everybody being on
the same page and everybody being
connected
and sometimes having divorced parents in
a room with somebody who's struggling
is a uh what's going on here
and a doctor telling everybody the same
thing and again
he's 26 and it may be a heartbreaking
chest can hardly breathe through my own
tear
situation where he's just gonna not let
anybody have access to anything at any
time
i've just seen persistence and continued
care
and and in person contact do worlds of
wonder
and i've also sat with parents outside
of psychiatric wards are
in my office and that have to explain to
them
i know you're paying for college i know
your
the psych visit is on your insurance but
your kid is signed away where they will
not talk to you
they think you are part of the problem
amen
there are few more awkward conversations
but i've had those they're hard
right that could happen to you what i
want there to be is a
record of me going to the ends of the
earth to try to get the right
information get everybody on the same
page
okay um that may be you reaching out to
her and here's what i say i would tell
you
if your son is diagnosed bipolar
if your son is diagnosed schizophrenia
schizophrenic
there's readings you can do there are
groups you can join there are
you know facebook groups with parents
with kids and there's
all kinds of resources you can join but
you don't even know what this is yet
or it might be just a bad trip with some
bad
um hallucinogens or some bad spice or
some bad k2 whatever it happens to be
and man it may just need to heal his
brain for a little while and then he's
going to be back to normal and then we
got to do the hard work of
why is he a drug addict right right so
that's again i think your best friend
right now is information and your best
friend is partnership
even if it's with somebody that you've
struggled being in partnership with
before
and here's the third and final thing
you're gonna have to deal with the grief
of the last five years you're gonna have
to deal with degree for the last seven
years you're gonna have to deal with the
grief
of my son's in a psych ward and i'm
however many miles away
and that means you're going to have to
find somebody who will hold you
accountable
to your diet choices to sleeping choices
to not trying to
work your way out of your feelings to go
sit with somebody
and just say hey i'm heartbroken whether
that's a local pastor or a local
counselor there in town
whatever that looks like for you but
you're going to have to be well and
whole through this deal
otherwise you're going to bring your own
chaos and your own
spin to this situation and it doesn't
need any more chaos doesn't any more
spin to this deal
so in order real quick you need real
information from real professionals who
know what they're talking about
whether it's going to be the
psychiatrists the doctors whomever you
got to get real information not a friend
of a friend not an art therapist who
knows somebody who knows somebody else
you need to get real information okay
real data
number two you and your uh
son's mom have got to agree and step dad
however awkward is for y'all
we're going to come together in
partnership over this deal we're going
to discuss things we're going to learn
from each other we're going to sit in
the same room
and be grown-ups for the benefit of our
son we're going to figure this thing out
okay and then you're going to do the
best you can to connect with that
hospital with your son with a social
worker with
whoever that is that can get you back
into relationship
with this young man because through
relationship
he can be um
i don't say convinced but through
relationship
he might decide okay i'll start taking
some medication through a relationship
he might think
okay i don't trust them but i trust you
and i don't trust you but i kind of
trust her
through a relationship that's your only
shot
at him getting some sort of healing him
getting some sort of wellness plan that
he can follow and continue on the rest
of
his days okay and then man
just dad to dad you got to be you got to
be present man
you gotta call him even if he won't talk
to you gotta write him letters even if
you don't write your back
every time you can rout through that
that town and if he says yeah i'll meet
you and he doesn't show up
that's on him not you and it will be
heartbreak it'll be hard
man john that's your son keep showing up
and keep showing up and keep showing up
okay i know it's hard i know it's hard i
know it's heartbreaking every time
keep showing up man thanks for that call